[Musique]
bonjour rachid Santaki bonjour Vous
organisez la plus grande dictée du monde
un événement grandeur nature qui réunit
la dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont l'amour de la langue française en
partage vous publiez ce livre une dictée
peut tout changer un témoignage
optimiste et fédérateur question pour
commencer il n'y a pas de provocation
est-ce que la dictée a encore un sens à
l'heure de l'écriture inclusive et des
anglicismes autobus
tout d'abord la dictée elle a pour but
de se connecter à ce côté cognitif
l'écriture cursive elle permet aussi de
réfléchir de se poser des questions à
l'heure ou justement on a on est
digitalisé on a aussi des débats sur
l'inclusion au niveau de l'écriture mais
c'est quelque chose vraiment d'essentiel
c'est un des fondamentaux l'écriture
cursive pour ceux qui nous prennent en
cours de route s'agit d'écrire à la même
extrêmement d'écrire la même chose que
de moins en moins de gens savent
visiblement aujourd'hui alors ceux qui
ont les fondamentaux savent que le
mouvement l'écriture cursive ça permet
de se poser des questions etc donc de se
connecter à soi-même et c'est vrai que
être avoir des outils ça peut nous
dématérialiser notre rapport à la
réflexion discernement etc donc ça c'est
la première je dirais c'est le premier
point de la dictée la langue vecteur
d'unité de partage oui complètement
quand on maîtrise la langue on peut
communiquer on peut partager on peut
faire beaucoup de choses et c'est quand
on n'a pas la langue qu'on a des
réactions on va on va avoir un rapport
physique la violence etc la dictée
rachides sont acquis le mot même sonne
comme effrayant en tout cas entre nous
tout le monde a un souvenir un peu
compliqué avec le plus que passer
première forme deuxième enfin bon on va
se passer les détails quel est votre
histoire à vous alors avec la dictée mon
histoire je l'avais occulté elle a
commencé avec mon père en fait donc ma
mère est française mon père et marocain
il est il arrive en France il venait de
Marrakech et il ne maîtrisait pas la
langue l'écriture comme il le souhaitait
car il était chauffeur de calèche à
Marrakech et c'était un de ses rêves
donc il a pris les cours du soir et dès
mon plus jeune âge en fait je faisais
des dictées à mon père je lui lisais des
mots des définitions alors pour moi
c'était pas quelque chose de confortable
c'était plutôt un calvaire car j'étais
CPC 20 je maîtrisais pas l'écriture mais
c'est comme ça en fait que j'étais bercé
et plus tard en fait ce ce ce parcours
c'est dicté c'est quelque chose qui est
ressorti et qui était assez naturel de
rassurer les gens justement parce que
vous avez évoqué la la dictée comme une
sanction et c'est une sanction bah le
mon exercice c'est la dédramatiser d'en
faire un jeu votre père qui avait un
caractère si j'ai bien compris assez
difficile mais quand vous lui faisiez la
dictée c'est lui qui devenait un peu
l'enfant une dictée peut tout changer
témoignage optimiste et fédérateur vous
dites Rachid Sandra qui que la dictée
peut être aussi un vecteur d'insertion
sociale expliqué non oui car la
aujourd'hui vous voyez vous pouvez
constater que les gens quand ils doivent
envoyer et qui ne maîtrise pas
l'écriture ils vont essayer de trouver
de tes techniques d'évitement et on voit
bien que c'est un marqueur social quand
on réussit à insérer les gens à les
accompagner dans la maîtrise de la
langue on peut trouver du travail on
peut avoir des activités on peut
vraiment s'insérer dans la société et
c'est vrai quand on ne maîtrise pas
cette langue on est exclu on est mis de
côté on vous voit intervenir sur les
quelques images que nous avons là dans
des salles de classe ce qui est
intéressant avec la grande dictée que
vous faites c'est que toutes les classes
d'âge sont mélangées pour quelles
raisons c'était l'objectif l'objet de la
dictée c'était de mélanger les publics
de faire du lien intergénérationnel de
s'amuser alors c'est vrai que la dictée
on l'associe à l'école et souvent on
fait ce blocage mais la dictée je
l'amène dans les maisons d'arrêt dans
les monuments historiques dans les
stades j'ai même eu l'occasion de faire
une dictée avec Thomas Pesquet pendant
sa mission on va en parler tout à
l'heure mais encore un petit mot de vous
rapidement est-ce que vous rachid
Santaki vous avez des mots dans la
langue française qui vous effraie
particulièrement est-ce que vous avez en
tête quelque chose que vous n'arrivez
pas à écrire par exemple oh j'ai bien
sûr j'ai des mots que je ne connais pas
évidemment je suis pas je suis pas un
dix copate pour taquiner mes amis
linguistes je suis plutôt quelqu'un qui
fait de la médiation à travers les mots
donc des mots énormément de mots que je
ne maîtrise pas ou mais il ne me font
pas peur les mots je dis souvent plus
jeune ou moins jeunes ce sont nos amis
et en fait quand je dis les mots sont
nos amis c'est de comprendre leur
étymologie leur histoire pour pouvoir se
rassurer donc je suis dans cette
démarche d'avoir vraiment d'être à
l'aise avec les mots même quand je ne
les connais pas merci de rassurer les
enfants parce que même si on a encore
passé l'âge du stylo rouge avec les
fameuses fautes on sait très bien
qu'est-ce que cela peut représenter
comme comme difficulté comme également
handicap par François quand il a zéro
faute enfin comme c'est arrivé dans dans
certaines façons de travailler on voit
bien que l'enfant peut perdre confiance
en lui la grande dictée donc on y arrive
vous vous avez lu dans des lieux
étonnants le Stade de France des centres
de détention Fleury-Mérogis si jamais
compris fleuri j'ai fait une
cinquantaine de maisons d'arrêts la
prison parce que c'était le lieu le plus
improbable pour faire des dictées pour
assembler des publics dans les maisons
d'arrêt lorsque je lis les dictées j'ai
des publics en détention donc homme
femme mineur adulte et j'ai aussi les
surveillants et même la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire et tout
le monde se retrouve dans une salle
polyvalente où là on fait la dictée
c'est quand même quelque chose de
d'assez impressionnant parce que la
prison c'est aussi la marge de notre
société sont des gens qui sont des
tensions par rapport à des faits et là
c'est d'utiliser la langue pour fédérer
et aussi donner espoir donner espoir
vouloir s'insérer vouloir voilà c'est un
temps de de partage avec les personnes
qui travaillent aussi dans
l'administration donc c'est assez
particulier et se dire qu'on a peut-être
pas échoué qu'on peut réussir cela
rachids sont acquis on vous surnomme le
Victor Hugo du ghetto quel est ce surnom
d'où vient il a disparu depuis je suis
devenu enfin devenu Rachid et sont des
des amis bah de Seine-Saint-Denis qui
pour eux l'écriture c'était pas quelque
chose de de qui nous était destinés
quand je dis nous habitant de
périphérique et il me suit surnommé
justement le Victor Hugo puis après
c'était Victor Hugo du ghetto donc
c'était plutôt une taquinerie je dirais
au départ la terre aussi vous avez été
éducateur sportif de boxe thaïlandaise
en quoi cette expérience a marqué votre
travail de terrain qu'elle a pu marquer
quoi que ce soit si ça a été le cas
parce que c'était le début de
l'engagement j'étais assez jeune à peine
une vingtaine d'années le sport c'était
un de mes refuges par rapport à
différents échecs que j'avais pu avoir
dans la vie et de me sentir utile de
pouvoir accompagner des gens d'avoir des
responsabilités ça a été la première
marche en fait j'ai franchi dans cette
dans l'engagement j'ai toujours gardé
après en parler de mon activité
professionnelle justement votre activité
professionnelle vous êtes également
auteur de de polar de roman policier le
genre est passé particulier comment
l'amoureux de la langue française que
vous êtes arrive-t-il à se glisser dans
la peau de des personnages que vous
créez et qui pour X raisons parfois ne
parle pas un Français châtier exactement
de l'argot ce sont des jeunes
effectivement un langage jeune comment
ça a été d'abord un travail de matière
vivant à Saint-Denis je me disais qu'il
y avait quelque chose d'intéressant à
faire dans le domaine de la fiction et
dans ces personnages que j'avais pu
observer qui était jeune et qui avait
qui choisissait des parcours des
trajectoires dans l'un délinquance et je
me suis imprégné de parcours j'en ai
fait de la fiction je trouvais ça
intéressant je trouve pas forcément le
côté lisse pertinent mais plutôt
pourquoi on bascule mais c'est à partir
de de cette envie j'ai commencé à
travailler dans ce sens et après ça
s'est développé c'est un véritable
plaisir et j'ai aussi sur les registres
de langue de langage comme vous le
précisiez ce qui m'intéresse n'est pas
d'essayer de devenir un Victor Hugo même
si justement c'était du réalisme ce que
faisait c'est de de capter en fait ces
langages et de réussir à les à les à les
mettre dans dans mes romans et faire
vivre en fait mes romans la dictée lutte
depuis l'espace par Thomas Pesquet
pourquoi les si loin
c'était ça a été une opportunité une
opportunité folle quand le musée de
terre et de l'espace m'a évoqué l'idée
de solliciter Thomas Pesquet je me suis
dit bon j'ai déjà fait le Stade de
France à mon avis dans l'espace je n'y
crois pas et finalement Thomas Pesquet a
accepté de lire la dictée et le 5
septembre 2021 j'étais
hors-sol c'était c'était fou et ça a
fait rêver énormément de gens Thomas
Pesquet il était populaire de faire la
dictée pendant qu'il était en mission
c'était faire rêver de nombreuses
personnes et ça a été un très bon moment
on a pu aussi vous entendre à la radio à
France Culture etc une dictée peut tout
changer Rachid sans acquis où va se
tenir la prochaine grande dictée j'ai
cru comprendre que vous aviez dans le
viseur le Champ de Mars à Paris ou le
parvis de l'hôtel j'ai pas mal de
perspectives les prochaines je serai à
Nice ce week-end et également au fil
entre là bas à Paris et ensuite pourquoi
pas les Champs-Elysées et pour finir
quels sont quels seraient les deux trois
textes de littérature française ou
francophone qui serait selon vous les
plus difficiles à l'orthographier je
pense qu'on sont plutôt soit des auteurs
qui vont inventer des mots ça c'est vrai
que c'est un Jules Verne l'avait fait
dans dans de ses ouvrages ou tout
simplement des des textes avec beaucoup
de passé simple ou des mots unités on a
parlé un moment de la fameuse dictée de
Mérimée exactement exactement celle-là
elle est elle est difficile mais en
réalité quand on l'a fait à plusieurs
reprises on maîtrise les difficultés les
accords les fameux cuissots de veau
cuissots de chevreuil la les arts etc
donc après c'est une histoire de
familiarisation avec les mots et le
texte et comprendre le sens un mois seul
quelle est la clé pour bien écrire sa
dictée pour faire zéro faute allez le
zéro faute je n'y crois pas forcément je
pense que c'est la répétition la
répétition travailler sur un texte
identifier ces difficultés et ensuite
une fois qu'on les a identifiés on peut
travailler là-dessus merci beaucoup
Merci à VOUS Rachid Santa qui d'être
venu jusqu'à nous une dictée peut tout
changer un témoignage optimiste et
fédérateur c'est aux éditions époque
épique c'est à la vitesse pari direct
l'information internationale continue
sur nos chaînes restées avec nous
[Musique]